kristin i know that you said you would
watch the crown in part to prepare for
this but i was wondering for each of you
what was your biggest asset in
researching diana
i think
genuinely it was for me it was this the
script it was the first thing that i've
read
i i
read the script before i watched any
documentaries or or um read any of the
books or biographies memoirs anything
like that and um
in going through all of the research
there is an ambiguity but such a
a a razor sharp precision to the
screenplay
you know
nothing is ever really articulated but
every everything that i know about her
everything that i learned about her
emotionally and doing
sort of logistical research real life
research it's all sort of
as a ghost shadowed in in the movie
somehow everything's touched on
mommy
family are all gathered in the drawing
room
they are waiting
[Music]
three days
that's it
so basically the research for me was
just about kind of
going through her life and burying like
you know
little things that i felt protective
over or or emotional
triggers to bring to sudden and feel
like i
felt a pr you know a closeness to her
actually like you know like uh
i felt like i absorbed her and then kind
of trusted the script is what i'm saying
yeah it brought a humanity to that
research seeing it on the i mean the
words of everything that you see you're
saying on screen pablo what about for
you
i i am um
of course the research the script
everything but what what really
helped me a lot was to talk to people
that is older than me um probably alive
with you know where they were probably
you know i don't know they were adults
when she was alive
because one of the things that made me
very curious is why is she affecting so
many people all around the world
why she how did she became
such a world icon and
what was people especially woman seeing
on her
and that that helped me and just talking
to people like my mother like talking to
people like
i don't know people at least in
different places of the world that
had a different relationship on her and
with her
and i talked to them i just understood
that
they were all just simple things even
stephen knight our writer said something
the first time i met him at a q a in
london really recently uh he said the
simplest thing and
you know this is from the horse's mouth
he was like
when she passed away i didn't have i
didn't know that i was gonna care so
much and i looked around and i saw
people
tearful and crying and we're english and
as a student of all things english as he
said he was just like i've never seen
this before
and he touches his face and his face is
wet with tears and he's like i've never
felt this before for a country that is
not to diminish this idea or generalize
it but the stiff upper lip thing is
pervasive it is a really true thing
and uh i i think to see somebody so
open raw pumping empathetic
and desperate and reaching out in a way
that is so craving she's craving that
connection personally as well so i think
everyone just went
me too
and um
yeah that some some people have that
talent she was born to privilege she was
you know connected with the royal family
from day one of her life but
she was still very normal and and
there's something regular in her that
people just felt identified with and
that is beautiful it's incredible for
for a movie i felt so intimate to to her
to you on screen kristen when i was
watching it feels like you're in the
room with her and i mean the
transformation your voice the physical
movements it's so powerful
what part of of getting her
right were you most nervous about or did
you work the hardest at in the physical
transformation probably in the area that
that requires zero preparation and
complete trust and like soul which is
the relationship that she has with her
children there there's no amount of
um
you know obviously we like hung out and
tried to get before we actually did did
the thing and did the scenes but um
the whole thing about watching her
within that space when her children are
close to
her they are
it's a nucleus it's it's it's a
three-headed animal sort of unstoppable
beast thing i feel like a reference for
that image
that is not like you know it's a it's a
it's a pretty universal image
you don't want to mess with moms you
just don't do that and i i just uh i
think she feels so embodied and so
unconditionally herself when when she's
with her kids and in all of the research
that i was like man you know that's what
we're protecting here
really comes across how that was her
happy place you know her and her boys
and that was what mattered most um that
being that ultimate freedom for her
those little moments of happiness in a
trapped world i wondered what is the
ultimate freedom or happiness for you
well i have a dog and i'm sure that like
uh when i have children ultimately i'll
realize that this is um
you know that there is i have room to go
but i think that this is tippy top just
like i do love my dog quite well
for me at this point
it's a pretty happy place i was talking
to somebody the other day about playing
a parent when you're not a parent yet
does it make you think about that in the
future what kind of place does that put
you in
i mean i'm a kid
of a parent yeah
i do know what it feels like that is
that exchanges you know i can't say with
certainty that i know what it feels like
to be a mother but i have you know
i have all the natural feelings
[Laughter]
yeah they can't change you have to
change
you have to be able to do things you
hate you hate there has to be two of you
it's the real one
and the one they take pictures of it
this scene that stuck with me so much
the character of charles tells diana
we're all two people in this family
we're our private self and our public
self and i wondered how much you might
both relate to that if you feel that
sense of being two versions of
yourselves uh in who you are in your
private life and then working in this
industry
well i think i have a different
relationship with that
myself i i have just one one side of the
coin but maybe even two i don't i do not
and i can't understand that's why that
bit of advice i don't know if you could
tell in the movie but just like it
doesn't compute for me i've gotten that
advice on a more superficial level it's
like oh interviews are hard sometimes
they're intimidating i want to say the
right thing in the right moment
just be a character just be someone else
it's like what is that even when i'm
being characters in the most profound
and elaborate sense
like i'm playing princess diana i'm
never not myself i think that that is
like psychosis talking because he says
that to her and then right after that he
says
you have to make your body do things you
hate
and those things are related and that is
the problem
[Music]